[Música]
la guerra en ucrania continúa y france24
hasta en el terreno en distintos puntos
del país para así recoger de primera
mano toda la información y es que
mientras las partes en el conflicto
tratan de buscar una solución
diplomática los ataques en el suelo
ucraniano no cesan los bombardeos
afectan directamente a la población
civil que sufre las consecuencias de la
guerra con miles de muertos y millones
de desplazados según la acnur ya son más
de 4 millones de refugiados más de 6
millones los desplazados internos porque
la guerra no soy igual en todo el país
hay ciudades más afectadas que otras
como mariupol por ejemplo que está
prácticamente en las ruinas hacer el
periodismo en el terreno en medio de una
guerra no es tarea fácil hay muchas
dificultades para trabajar en gran
medida por el difícil acceso a las
fuentes de información y para conocer
entonces de primera mano cómo ha sido
cubrir todo este conflicto quiero
saludar en este momento a una de
nuestras enviadas especiales hasta hace
poco estuvo en ucrania es catalina gómez
ángel corresponsal de france 24 en
español cata qué bueno tenerla aquí en
directo américa de francés un gran
abrazo desde bogotá hablemos catalina
entonces de las diferencias de cómo se
vive la guerra según en cada parte del
país donde usted estuvo en varias
localidades en varias ciudades cómo está
la situación ahora
bueno muy buenos días es interesante
porque realmente el país
geográficamente y también en la guerra
está dividida de cierta manera en tous
si bien la parte oeste del país donde
anímico se han desplazado la mayoría de
esos 6 millones que hablan las naciones
unidas pues han habido ataques en el vip
en el bando franquista en muchas
localidades pero están muy enfocadas a
objetivos militares ahí generalmente la
población civil no está siendo atacada
entonces allí la guerra se vive de una
manera es la guerra está presente por
los desplazados por el temor por la ola
porque como está afectada la economía
muchos comercios es o estuvieron
cerrados durante muchas semanas entonces
si la población está movilizada a ayudar
a ayudar a quienes llegan a ayudar a
quienes están en el frente de batalla o
ayudar a esas poblaciones que están
realmente afectadas pero luego ya nos
vamos a otras poblaciones por ejemplo
como en sap orilla donde estuvimos que
ayer a aquí recibía por ejemplo la gente
que estaba oyendo de mariupol es una
ciudad muy grande especialmente más
grande y extensa una ciudad muy al
estilo soviético con construcciones no
muy altas pero sí muy grandes con unas
grandes avenidas y luego vemos cómo está
afectada por esos miles y miles de
personas que llegan todos los días no
solamente desde mariupol sino de muchas
poblaciones o que si bien estar en el
control de las fuerzas rusas están
siendo disputadas ahí se ve pues
obviamente el dolor de la guerra contra
estas personas acabando de salir
contando historias que cada vez son son
más son más rompedoras gente que lleva
días sin comer gente que ha visto
cadáveres en las calles gente que ha
tenido que calentarse con el fuego
en las calles porque no hay no hay otra
opción que tuvieron que dejar a sus
familias atrás porque estaban en
diferentes partes de la ciudad entonces
acá está la ciudad yo no estuve en hard
kid por ejemplo que es una ciudad
bastante afectada o en regiones cercanas
a quienes pero cada ciudad se vive de
una manera diferente pero la guerra está
presente en toda ucrania y eso es una
realidad claro catalina y también usted
te hablaba de la movilización ciudadana
porque también hemos visto como en estos
genes en las guerras y los desastres
naturales que ahí sacamos todo lo bueno
que tenemos los seres humanos como hace
la ciudadanía para movilizarse para
ayudar a sus connacionales que están
pues peor digamos aquellos en esas
ciudades más afectadas que usted decía y
también le quiero preguntar catherine en
esta misma pregunta qué pasa con las
personas que se quedan cuál es la
situación realmente tienen miedo o no
tienen miedo porque deciden quedarse
usted que ha tenido la oportunidad
hablar con tantas personas
si mire yo me quedé bastante sorprendida
como se dice en las guerras obviamente
hay hay una gran movilización y la
población se moviliza para apoyarse los
unos con los otros pero debo decir que
lo que viene ucrania realmente me me
conmovió es es un país entero realmente
movilizado no solamente a defenderlo
sino a apoyar a aquellos o que bien
están siendo afectados por por la guerra
o que están luchando para defender el
país entonces por ejemplo en odessa que
es un lugar donde yo pasé en bastante
bastantes días por ejemplo imágenes que
la población se moviliza para
entrar en esas bolsas de arena pero no
solamente eso veríamos gente que el
dueño del panadero que hacía pan para
mandar al frente de batalla gente que
tiene unos unos como locales unos food
corts donde tienen diferentes
restaurantes como un hall de comidas
entonces todos se movilizan para
volverse un lugar donde la gente trae
colchones trae comida trae ropa y desde
ahí empiezan a repartir no solamente en
la región sino que empiezan a mandar a
otras regiones de ucrania donde están
muchísimo más afectadas y entonces en
ese sentido realmente fue entre toda la
tristeza pues también fue cubrir una
guerra donde cubríamos la otra historia
de la guerra ese país movilizándose para
para apoyar y por ejemplo estuvimos en
esta población de muy cerca amigo
nicolás es así es un frente de banda ya
estuvimos allí y vimos por ejemplo como
unas señoras mayores que vivían en unos
resguardo nos decían que bueno que a
pesar de todo tenían comida porque les
llegaba la ayuda humanitaria a los
mismos habitantes de esas ciudades
cercanas les llevaban comida
ahora acá está también usted cómo pudo
hacer para trabajar en una situación tan
difícil de guerra en ucrania como era
esta cuestión del acceso a la
información de las fuentes oficiales
como hacía como para para tenerla la
información bajo betty más clara posible
ha sido una guerra difícil pero porque
yo en lo personal yo yo cubro
orientemedio realmente y entonces era la
primera vez que vi bien si las guerras
se parecen unas a otras era la primera
vez que cubría ucrania y consideré que
era una guerra muy difícil de cubrir
primero porque el acceso a los frentes
el acceso a esa guerra es bastante
limitado y cada vez hay más resquemor
frente a los periodistas si bien
necesitan de los medios internacionales
porque ellos saben que en la medida que
haya presencia del periodismo
internacional pues hay mayor apoyo
mundial para closer que realmente son la
población civil la que está siendo
atacada por ejemplo pues al mismo tiempo
raúl el acceso es muy difícil muy
difícil y cada vez hay más desconfianza
por ejemplo la gente cree que muchos
rusos están infiltrados como periodismo
y periodistas entonces cada vez que
dejan tomar menos fotos cada vez te
dejan sacar menos las cámaras así que es
una pierna que todavía falta muchísimo
por documentar esa verdadera guerra sea
verdadero conflicto
queda mucho por contar pues cata gracias
por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de nuestro canal de france 24
simple hacer haber conversado con usted
en este rato podríamos aquí hablar horas
pero como usted sabe el tiempo la
televisión es corto así que pues ya la
tengo que estar catalina muchísimas
gracias por estar con nosotros un gran
abrazo
a ustedes muchísimas gracias